each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'm happy to introduce nilesh he's a PhD
student at the University of Washington
his advisor is dance with you he even
visited us in the summer of two thousand
four I think he's done some pretty
foundational work on managing uncertain
databases and he's going to tell us a
little bit about that he is in fact even
given a tutorial at sigmod on this so
he's going to tell us more about what is
done over to you thank you for the kind
of direction I am really excited to be
here and to present you my work on
managing uncertainty using permissive
databases so let me start by giving you
a very simplistic view of a database
their queries their facts and you get
answers but I want to point you the
three basic assumptions that went into
the design of a database so the fact
they are very precise and they are all
correct facts the queries they're rich
in structured but they're very precise
and answers I what you get by logical
implication from the facts so when
databases were designed the applications
in mind where inventory and payrolls and
this model has served those kinds of
applications deals weather would past
couple decades but now there's a whole
new set of applications which are
emerging which challenge some of these
basic assumptions of databases what does
this new applications look like so this
applications that work on large number
of bridge and heterogeneous data there's
so much structured data on the web and
there is a constant push towards adding
more structure to the data and the
applications that are trying to work on
this data they have to deal with the
problem of heterogeneity this also
pushed towards automation and using
modern world machine learning algorithms
whatever data extraction tasks which
include extracting information from text
matching schemas of different databases
and linking the records among different
databases and other is all of these
applications they give you answers with
certain confidences and the data the
produce is uncertain so users they often
find themselves
writing queries over data which still
did not create and they cannot exactly
specify the query over such databases
and and in the presence of so much
uncertainty you just want not a set of
answers but a ranked list of answers
based on relevance is it is a model
being popular popularized by the search
engines today so say see there is
uncertainty in data inquiries and pretty
answers and the traditional model of
databases based on logic is inadequate
to deal with this issues so I'm going to
give an example of two applications that
to illustrate this issues i am talking
about the first application is a movie
very engine and the objective here is to
allow users to right way is jointly over
three different data sources and so here
are the three data sources there is an
internet movie database it's it is a
large and extensive collection of
structured data about movies and actors
and directors there's amazon movie dvds
so you can put the website and you can
find information about all the movies
and the dvds in slices and there is a
web service that actually allows you to
access all this data and then there's
this usenet newsgroup postings so this
huge collection of text files containing
reviews or different movies and you want
to find you want to build a system where
you can use all this data to write
queries so how would you go about
building for the system so you have this
IMDb database it's in relation format
you can just load it into the database
with amazon you have to write you to do
some more work here to write some lip
service wrapper we can extract all the
data you can load it into the database
into a few tables with the newsgroup
previous here to do some more work you
have to use some kind of information
extractor that extracts the name of the
movies from the text and then you have
to use some kind of classifier that
looks like the Virgin it text it tries
to find the polarity of the review
whether it is a good leave you at a bad
review so you have all this data loaded
into the tables and now you can write
queries for instance against you can say
find dvds of movies which are highly
rated by arnold schwarzenegger
it's a equity that involves all the
three databases so so far so good you
have this data you're writing queries
the problem is the queries do not return
any answer and answer the there are lots
of reasons why this happens so if you
look inside the IMDb database and the
amazon database they represent movies
differently so the same movie may be
represented in different planes of
different databases and you need some
kind of a machine learning algorithm
that tries to look at all the evidences
and place to find a confidence for each
pair of movies in fact when we did an
exact search we found out the thirty
percent of the movies we represented
differently in the two databases so next
if you look at the information extractor
it's going to produce produce things
with errors is going to miss certain
things it is going to produce them
things which are incorrect if you have
confidences associated with each
extracted name and then the classifier
it's also probabilistic so it is going
to give a probability associated with
each day whether it is a good review or
a bad review then you need to match the
movies from the IMDb database and the
user database so that is another source
of uncertainty and finally when you look
at the query the terms in the query need
not be exactly the terms in the database
and therefore you again need some kind
of a matching to match the keywords in
the queries with the database so there's
this whole in the whole system you see
they're showing different sources of
uncertainties which you need to model
and you need some kind of a logic that
allows applications to store all these
uncertainties and allow users to write
queries here is a totally different
application it's about another analyzing
the data privacy so let's say you are a
medical agency and you want to publish
data about your patients for for
research purposes at the same time you
want to make sure that you are not
disclosing any sensitive information
about an individual so you will try to
engine anonymize the data so you will
remove the names you just publish that's
the age weight zip code interface
and you may want to hide some of the
values if you think they are sensitive
in disclosing the information about any
person and then attack comes and tries
to find out the diseases of individual
person and and attack i may go and find
some public database maybe from the
voter registration database and it and
the tiger finds information about
individuals along with let's say there
eh smoking habits and zip code now you
may want to join this to databases to
answer the queries you want except that
you cannot do it there is no column to
join on the you can join on age and zip
code maybe but there is no unique
identifier however the attacker knows
certain other things for instance
there's some statistics which the
attacker may know it may be is expected
about patients in each zip code is five
or maybe a smoker is much more likely to
have lung cancer so using this
statistics and the fact that I commit
try to guess which person has which
disease and here the problem is how do
you quantify the uncertainty in the
query answers based on the statistical
information this is an application where
uncertainty is good because it's it's
preserving the privacy of individuals
but we need a way to quantify the
uncertainty and there are several other
applications so there is scientific data
integration there is sensor networks
this personal information management
while it's all of these applications
have uncertainty as a fundamental
problem and it appears in various
different forms the inconsistencies
their incompleteness and the statistical
knowledge so what we need is a framework
that can represent this different kinds
of uncertainties and allow the users to
to query them in this talk I am going to
propose a probabilistic framework with
the goal of a uniform representation of
probabilities and there are three issues
that i am going to talk about so how do
you define the semantics for
probabilistic databases traditional
databases were based on first order
logic but what kind of logic do you use
in such a database how do you represent
the uncertainties in different sources
in such a system and most importantly
how do you answer
where is efficiently so this is going to
be the three main topic of my talk
select stack with semantics I am going
to define a very clean and simple way to
think about probabilistic databases so a
probability database it's simply a
probability distribution were all
possible databases and any for any
database with positive probability is
called a possible world so this is this
is the possible word semantics which is
widely used in knowledge representation
to represent uncertainty and here's an
example so there are four different in
positions of probability databases for
different possible words these are the
four tables each of them has the
probability that adds up to one and so
the possible words are these four tables
how do you define queries over such a
database well the answer to a query its
set of tuples along with probabilities
and to find the probability of a given
triple you use this expression which
says that you value to query on all
possible databases and you look which of
them give you the triple-a the answer
and you add all the probabilities and
that gives you the probability of the
tuple let me give an example this is
this is a database with four possible
words and the query is written all the
years that have both high in the low
rated movie so if you executor to get
the following two answers let's look at
1972 in the first instance it appears
with both the high in the low rated
movie same thing with the second
instance and and that's only two
instances so you add the probability of
the first four instances and the same
thing with the other ear so such as
summarized the semantics it's a very
clean and simple way to think about
probabilities every query has a
well-defined semantics symmetrical
complex the problem is there are too
many possible words to do so we need a
good representation to store all the
possible words worry is not a problem
so set of tuples of probabilities
right yeah so the idea is to us and we
and the idea is to present to the user
the most relevant answers so you have
the main motivation is for the users to
find most 11 answers given the
uncertainty
so next I'm going to talk about
representation and a simplest way to
represent a set of possible versus using
a triple independent database so this is
an example there are two tables and
every table has a new column called
probability which shows the probability
of that tuple being correct and all
other triples are independent so given
such a database you can generate all
possible worlds and this how you do it
so i'm looking at a single table so
every subset of this table is a possible
world and you can derive the probability
from from the tip from the input
probabilities so in this table there the
p1 p2 is there and p4 is their first
probabilities p 1 times p 2 times 1
minus p 3 because it's not there sp4 and
you can get a probability for each
possible world so that defines a
possible word database from the triple
independent database and given that all
the queries have a well-defined
semantics well before I go into a very
very evaluation let me give an example
an application of this representation
the next thing you want to have build an
application for that supports queries
with similarity predicates and you
assume all the details deterministic so
you have these two tables cast and firms
everything is all the data is
deterministic but you want to support
queries like this which says written all
the films with actor name is similar to
Kevin and the title is similar to rain
so now you can look at these predicates
and you can apply them to the tables so
you look at each cast and you see how
well the actor matches the Kevin you use
your favorite algorithm to match them
and then you get this confidences with
each tuple and you get your pleasure
other predicates affirmed you again get
a set of probabilities so now the
resulting database you evaluate the
query the resulting database to generate
set appearances with probabilities and
this gives us a way to define semantics
for any complex sequel query which
similarity predicates
so the problem is given a tuple
independent eater base how do you
evaluate queries and you do not want to
consider construct all possible words to
evaluate this which would be exponential
so before I go into that let me give a
bit of a history of the problem it's the
problem which which has a long history
and people have been looking at this for
more than 20 years and yet it was not a
very well understood problem let me give
you some of the approaches which people
have considered some systems then we
support a restricted set of queries for
which they know how to compute the
answers some systems use exponential
algorithms and in the worst case that
amounts to constructing all possible
worlds some systems just compute the
bounds and probabilities without
actually giving any guarantees and then
there are some systems that use a dog
semantics which is very specific to a
given query or a given data so what is
the hard about peer evaluation let me
give an example we have as this two
tables a film and a cast along with
probabilities and I want to answer this
query which says return all the ears in
the film table which have a matching
movie in the cast table CSE 1995 has
this movie f1 that appears here 1982 has
a movie f2 that appears here 1971 does
not have any matching movie so well if
you evaluate this query will get the
destroyer the answers the question is
what is the probability next took in
1995 for this to be the answer this
tuple p1 has to be in the database and
at least one of this q1 q2 q3 had to be
in for the film IDF went to be in the
database and if you look to compute the
probability you will get this expression
which is p1 times the probability
probability that at least one of this
tree is there and that gives you the
xsplit the probability for 1995 with
1982 it looks much more complex because
1982 appears twice in this table so the
point is this expressions can get very
complicated and the question is how to
compute them in general given any query
and given any database
so before I go into that let me give a
brief is Jeff how you how do it in a
traditional database and you use it
using relational operators so you have a
joint operator that takes two tables and
it computes for each pair that have the
same join attribute it computes an
entering the output table and there is a
project operator that just takes a set
of tip it to Berlin it just removes a
certain attribute so in this case it
removes the actor attribute and as a
result seven triples and they collapse
into a single tuple so now let us try to
exchange this operators to compute
probabilities and here is umut here's
how you may go about it so if you if
you're joining two tuples you compute a
new probability which is just their
product and if I doing a projection that
that collapses several two percent of
same triple you just use this formula
which which is the probability that at
least one of them exist now this is this
is just a heuristic because it's
assuming that the input this operators
have independence to independent tuples
now although you may start with your
database which is independent their
computing this expressions there they
can have very strange correlations and
so this approach may not always give you
the right answer but let's see how well
it works so this example that I
considered before I have simplified the
table to just contain single year and
the answer to the query as we recall is
this expression let's try to compute
this using relational operators we start
from the two tables you join them you
get three tuples along with the
probability which are their product and
then do a projection the ear you get
this single expression except that it's
wrong it does not match with the answer
which we which we evaluated before so
what went wrong is server assumptions
about independence did not hold at each
intermediate level and therefore this
plan it give you a wrong answer but
let's not lose hope let us try a
different plan so you start with
two tables you first do a projection to
just compute the film ID in the cast
table and then you join it with the
other table and then you get the same
answer but this time with the right
probability so positio at two different
plants can give you different answers
sometimes they can be right sometimes
they can be wrong here you can prove
that this plan on the right it always
gives you the right probably it is no
matter what the input data base is and
we call such a plan a safe plan so the
question is given any query how do you
come check whether it has a safe plan
and what you do if the quit does not
have any safe plan let me answer the
first question first so do you want any
query how do you compute a safe plan and
for this you need to express the query
in the conjunctive form so this is a
query which has three relations movie
actor and director and and there are
four attributes title actor agent
director and you want to check whether
there's some values of this attributes
that make each of these three predict
it's true sir given such a query to
compute a safe language start from a
graph it's nodes are all the relations
and its edges it saves the hypergraph
will the edges for every variable here
there is an edge containing all the
relations having that variable so if you
look at title it just appears in movie
fits it's the edge containing this movie
the H it just appears an actor if you
look at actor it appears in actor as
well as movie so the edge contains both
the relations and the director it just
appears in this relation say build this
graph this graph has a very nice
property so given any two sexes there is
at this joint or one is completely
contained in another because such a
graph a hierarchical graph and we said
that we say that the resulting query is
hierarchical and given such a query we
know how to compute the safe plan and it
is as follows so you work top-down you
look at the whole graph and you build a
plan recursively drop down so this query
has this graph has two components
so when I defined two components you'd
make a join the right side would be a
would be a plan for this component the
left side would be a plan for this
component so then you go into the right
side and this has a single component
with top attribute director so in that
case you apply the in that case you do a
projection that removes that attribute
and then you go inside that's the rule
so then you go to the left it has a
single attribute single component with
actor as the top attribute so you remove
that attribute and you go down now there
are two components you do a join and
then you go inside each one of them so
you find a plan and you can prove that
this plan will give you the right
probabilities no matter what the input
data base is and this is the way you can
compute a safe zone for any query here
is a different way it also has three
relations actor moving director let's
try to make the graph for this query so
the actor attribute it appears in the
actor ization and the movie relation and
the director attribute it appears in
movie and director and here you see this
graph is not hierarchical because there
are two states that intersect but none
of them is contained in another and here
you can prove that there is no safe plan
so given this movie you can compose
these operators to give it the right
probabilities in all cases but you can
still ask can you add some new operators
that would give a plan for this graph
and we answered that negatively using
this following result so we show that
for every simple conjunctive query one
of the following holds so either the
queries hierarchical in which case its
complexity is in ptang and I give you
the algorithm for computing it you first
find a safe plan for it and just and you
execute the plan and that gives you a
free time algorithm to evaluate the
query but the other case is then the the
queer is not hierarchical in that case
you can prove that it's the complexities
Sharpie complete which which means
there's no way you can avoid it in p
time unless P equals NP so no matter how
many operators you add into algebra you
will never find a plan for
is query okay so such queries do occur
in practice and what you do about them
we have two techniques to take care of
them so the good news is this queries
are easy to approximate and in fact you
can there is an algorithm that
approximates it to any precision you
want in polynomial time and it uses a
Monte Carlo simulation technique that
just simulates the database and tries to
find estimate the probabilities we also
have a variant of this technique to just
compute the top K and here the idea is
the user is not interested in the exact
probabilities the user wants the top k
answers which are most relevant to the
user and in that case you can optimize
the algorithm to just compute the top
cave without access spending lots of
time finding the exact probability of 2%
the bottom which are not going to make
into the top gear and that that speeds
up the algorithm by at least effect on
the order of magnitude right so yeah the
most top cave cheapest it is
okay and so far i only discussed
databases where all the trip as an
independent i will talk a bit about
correlations so when natural way to
represent correlations is using
independent and disjoint tuples and
here's an example so here the troopers
are divided into groups and in this to
to perform a group and all the troopers
here are disjoint so it says either
Kevin Bacon lives in Seattle or in LA
but not both and so these are not
independent but these are disjoint
events and this is another group where
both both of them are disjoint and
across the groups are independent this
representation comes very naturally with
inconsistent data bases where you have
to contribute contradictory facts and
you don't know which one of them is true
and you want to store them as exclusive
event in your database and we have
techniques to evaluate queries and we
have safe than algorithms for this
representation another way to express
correlations is using conjunctive views
so you start from a set of tuples which
are independent and disjoint and then
you express correlations using
conjunctive queries themselves and you
can show that this is using this
representation it is a completely
presentation so you can store any
probability distribution or databases
inside for many applications there is a
very natural way to represent the
correlations in this form I don't I
don't have a I will skip the details
here anyway I mean earlier you said the
query result itself is not a
probabilistic database right i mean the
problem is that you get
the very result are not in the same
representation model as the original
database so but here you are saying
something different so the query results
they are not it's a prop it is a
database it is a probability database it
but it may not be a tipple independent
data base so if you start from a set of
relations should set up tables which are
independent you write a query and then
you will get a new table the triples
there is a very strange correlations and
in fact we can show that you can capture
all possible correlations by using query
do you know what kind of correlations
they have a minumum you mean each book
it's one thing to say I can capture all
possible correlations that given a query
what is the kind of correlations of
those tuples I mean the tuples in the
resume file but the query defines the
correlation it's the query defines
accumulation and for many applications
the process which generates the data
itself or query and you can start from
some basic independent events and you
can write the ferries that capture the
data generation process which does it
mean if I take a pair of doubles in the
query result and if I want to know when
I don't know what what does it mean to
say what's the correlation between the
pair of tuples and equerry river can I
get some how are they related or you can
just ask what's the probability that
both of them I true yeah
and you can you can answer that query by
looking at the credit that generated
those tuples yeah so all your complex
your reserves in these alternative
presentations because I am assuming that
your earlier is elsewhere for
independent yes so we have results so we
again we have a dichotomy result we show
that every query is either p time or
shafi complete the boundary is different
the boundary ships but we again have the
tip so the Monte Carlo simulation
technique we extend it to to this
representation and the safelink
technique will succed into this
representation and four for the
conjunctive use you can actually just
compose your query with the original
query and and then all the results
follow
which pretty so forgiving any user query
that you want to evaluate on this
representation you can just compose the
user query with the queries that
generate the data and then you can just
use the existing techniques to value the
query but we want this compulsion kind
of show up this highs of I'm not sure
you can sit and talk about yes let me
move on to statistics so I showed you
the other application where you want to
use statistics to find the probabilities
of certain queries so statistical
knowledge it's just it another kind of
uncertain knowledge and here the
challenges how do you even define the
semantics of queries and then how do you
define answer queries efficiently using
statistics let me give an example let's
say a relation containing names and
phone numbers and let's say you know the
size of the domain for the names and
phone numbers of n which is a very large
number think of all possible names in
the universe and all possible 10-digit
phone numbers but you are some of the
following statistical knowledge that the
expected size of the relation is 50 and
now somehow you figure out that the
person John is in the database and
separately figure out that this phone
number 1234 is in the database so you
can you can express it using the
following conjunctive query which says
that John is there and the phone number
is there but now you want to answer the
following query this joint have the
phone number 1234 and here you would
expect the answer to be drew with
probability of 10 verse 50 because you
believe there are 52 points in the
database so that is around 10 or 50
probability that this defects are
talking about the same tuple so how do
you how do you generalize this intuition
to define a semantics for for answering
queries with statistics and here we use
a technique called the asian analysis
from premier which which says that given
the statistics you generate a
probability distribution over all
possible databases which captures a
belief and it's called the prior
distribution
and then the probability of Q over this
distribution is the problem is a prior
probability that you believe the queries
true and the probability of q given V
it's the probability of the query being
true after you see the observed facts
and the difference between these two
probabilities it gives an information it
gives you a measure of information which
the view discloses about the query the
question is how do you use statistics to
generate apply distribution and here we
observe that each statement of
statistics is in fact a statement on the
probability distribution when I say the
expected size of the relation is 10 I am
saying that if you look at this
distribution this this distribution and
you compute the expected size over all
databases you should get a value 10 so
every statement it imposes a constraint
on the distribution that you can use and
you want to choose a distribution that
satisfies all your statistics the
problem is the set of constraints do not
uniquely define a distribution so here
we use another technique from knowledge
representation called the maximum
entropy principle which says that among
all the distributions that satisfy your
statistics choose the one with maximum
entropy and the entropy is a measure of
the randomness of the distribution and
this gives you a distribution which is
as random as possible but that still
satisfies all of you do all of your
statistics let's go back to an example
and see how the semantics work on this
example so you have here the state
statistics that the expected size is 50
and you see the following two facts
given by V and you want to find the
probability of the square eq the first
look at let's look at the maximum
entropy distribution given the
statistics and you can it's a very
simple distribution so the domain size
for names and phone numbers is n so
there are n squared possible to pulse in
the universe you pick each one of them
independently with probability 50 over N
squared and then you can you can even
see that the expected size of such a
distribution is is 50 and this is the
one that maximizes the entropy so now
let let us look at the probability of
the query
on the distribution so if you just look
at the query its probability is 1 over
it's something which is whenever n where
n is a domain size and if you assume
that the domain is very large that this
goes to 0 as the domain goes to infinity
which is very intuitive it says that if
you don't know anything about the
database then the prior probability that
the square is true is 0 but if you look
at the conditional probability of query
given the fact it converges to a value
which is one over 51 so it says that
even though you may have a really nice
domain once you see the following two
facts that the John and the one two
three four is in the database the
conditional probability of a living
through is one or 51 which is which is
not zero and so the question is how do
you evaluate where is given a bunch of
statistics and here we found a very
interesting connection to random graphs
so the distribution which I just showed
you it's precisely the a dish to any
random graph which has been widely
studied in the graph theory and then the
query valuation over using statistics it
just amounts to computing conditional
probabilities over random glass and in
fact we we got some new results on the
existence of conditional probabilities
and some complexity bounds for computing
them over a class of random glass so so
far I showed you the theory behind a
probability database let me describe to
you some of the systems that we build
and our experiences with it so one of
the system that we built is called
mistake it's a general purpose
probabilistic database system that
allows you to store probabilistic data
and query eight it has a query language
which looks which is sequel but it's
it's it's extended with a few operators
to allow similarity play decades and
then into the data definition language
that allows you to describe the
uncertainty in the data and it's it's
build it it's built on top of a
standardization database they take user
queries it compiles them into standard
sequel queries and it just execute them
in the in the database and it embeds all
the probability calculations as into
sequel queries
let me show you some other features
mystic as so you can you can have
probabilistic tables in the schema and
you can describe which attributes are
probabilistic and whether they're
independent or disjoint the sequel has
the following two new constructs you can
say name is similar to Kevin and you can
associate a confidence with each
predicate so you are saying that maybe I
am completely wrong maybe the name is
something totally different and I only
certain confidence on a predicate so
these are two semantically different
constructs which are treated differently
you can certificate statistics you can
say every age and zip code has around
ten names and then you can have a
probabilistic views so you can say you
can just write any sequence where you
want and you can restore them as a new
view and the users they can just use it
as a new relation in writing the queries
and here we have to be careful because
we can adjust or the output of the query
we also have to store that exact way
that generated that the output because
the output will have some correlations
and the square describes what those
correlations are the mystic was
developed in collaboration with lots of
people we so the movie application I
described to you in the beginning we
actually implemented it on mistake and
we demonstrated it in the sigmoid
conference let me escape to another
system which I am working on currently
it's it's a system for biological data
integration that integrates 12 different
public databases contain information
about proteins jeans and diseases and
here is the here's the query model so
the scientists they don't want to write
sequel queries they want to they want to
browse the data starting from a very
simple query here the snapshot from the
system so you start from some query
maybe are looking for some specific
tipple let's say the breast cancer gene
and then the user it can click on any
node and that allows and that joins the
node with other databases so maybe you
have looking at the same gene in a
different database or maybe are looking
at
associated with that gene in a different
database so you can click on node and
that will expand it by joining it with
other data sources and you can keep
browsing multiple data sources using
this way the problem is this links had
to be approximate so let's say you have
a protein and you want to find the same
protein in different database well no
two databases right proteins in the same
way and you have to use some kind of a
sequence alignment algorithm that
matches two proteins and and you
sometimes will find a good man sometimes
we find not so good match the same
diseases they are written in different
ways so you'll have to use some string
predicates to match diseases and so on
and also different data sources the
content information with different
reliability so there are some data
sources which are very authentic and
which contain all the accurate
information there's some databases where
anyone can go and add the experiment and
which are not very reliable so the
scientists they want to make sense out
of their browsing in terms of the links
there following and in terms of the data
which they're getting and he is actually
a snapshot in system with just two
levels complete expansion and you see
that there's no way you can make sense
out of that this information simply
because of the number of data sources
and the perfect matches across these
data sources so our approach is we
associate certain uncertainty matrices
with each of the data source and with
each link between two data sources so
that gives you some kind of a confidence
with each node and edge in your browsing
graph and then we use the probabilistic
very semantics to find the relevance of
each node to the user and we present
this nodes to the user the decreasing
order fill avensis to guide their
browsing search so so this a project
that I am doing in collaboration with
the medical school at Washington and
with lots of have their many
collaborators so we we built the first
prototype of the system and we showed it
to the scientists and we got some very
increasing feedback okay let me let me
give you a conclusion so let me give you
a summary of the other of my results
so I defined a prophecy database as a
framework to manage uncertainty in
different applications and I looked at a
representation of data base with
explicit probabilities and here the main
dessert was a dichotomy theorem which
said every query has a complex division
either p time or sharpy complete for the
p10 quitters I gave a Pete safe plant
algorithm to evaluate them and for the
Sharpie queries I give a Monte Carlo
simulation to visit them approximately
and then we consider several extensions
to the model to handle correlations i
select statistics there we found very
interesting connections with random
graphs and we found some new results on
the existence of computing probabilities
and the complexities for computing them
and then we build systems mistake and
you too so now there is lots of
excitement in the community on about
publicity databases and these are some
of the projects currently going on in
various groups that look at
probabilistic data let me describe to
some of the other work which I did I did
some work on video optimization where I
looked at optimizing multiple queries at
the same time trying to exploit their
comments of expressions I did some work
on on peer-to-peer databases where I
looked at efficient indexing schemes to
n securities efficiently I looked at I
did some work in machine learning the
result that the problem of
classification in the presence of an
adversary was trying to fool the
classifier and then I did some work on
user preferences in database queries
which we looked at ways to estimate the
cost and cardinality of such queries let
me is a discussion of the problems that
I want to work on so setting databases
in yeah there they walk down different
paths for a long time but it's time when
this should come together so this
there's so much research in AI on
managing uncertainty there's so much be
searching databases on on scaling on
scalability to large data sets and when
it's techniques with recognized and
certain scale to dodge data sets
so some specific questions are can we
actually incorporate the graphical
models in the eye into databases and can
we in fact use databases to speed up the
influencing in the algorithms there some
specific problems having to work on
aggregates / queries it's a it's a very
challenging and very important problem
which has applications in
privacy-preserving data mining where you
look at lots of aggregates over your
data and you want to reason about the
original data generated it and there are
so applicants over online analytical
processing / uncertain data we want to
compute certain aggregates to for your
decision for making decisions as I want
to look at constraints would probably
still databases which again has lots of
applications in in in detained in data
exchange constraints are often used to
describe mappings between two different
data sources and if you if you have an
answer uncertain data and you want to
map it to defend schema how does this
translate in terms of the constraints
they also it has updates in an important
role in data cleaning where you have
some dirty data and you think certain
constraints hold over the data and you
want to reason about that and finally I
want to use all this machinery to build
new applications there are some very
important applications like personal
information management scientific data
integration wherein certainty plays a
very fundamental rule and each app such
application will bring certain issues
that are want to look at City conclude I
would say that the new the next
generation of database applications have
uncertainty as the fundamental problem
and a probabilistic database can provide
the platform that can drive these
applications sits end of my talk thanks
so so you said you work with a couple of
applications in the mystic any other
project so in sometimes the
effectiveness or usefulness of this
framework is somewhat based on how
accurate how good the input
probabilities of it in those two
examples you know what are their expects
on how difficult it was to get the right
so in this application sum of the
probabilities came from machine learning
algorithms that used a probabilistic
model to find the probabilities and some
of the private is just came from the
users for instance some of the databases
in fact have a rating between one and
ten hoor arrival the experiments where
and we used some simple heuristics to
convert them into probabilities our
experience is that the answers we get
are pretty robust to variations in the
input probabilities so if you have was
there some methodology whether it and
that it was effective
right so we have we have used the update
with some synthetic data where where we
have looked at the pub the decision and
recall of our system based on input
probabilities but what we need is some
kind of big user study that that can
really evaluate such a system the main
problem is we don't there is no labeled
data set out there they're making this
evaluate of a system the den so many
data sets from machine learning
algorithms but so far it's it's a there
is no data set for a probabilistic
database we had we had some anecdotal
experiences with scientists and when we
demonstrated our system in the
conference but at some point I would
like to have a benchmark where we can
different systems can actually evaluate
the their precision recall
question so you mentioned this scaling
up is important we run any retested
however anthems for curry evaluation
scheme so the the movie application that
you built a mistake the totally teri
sighs was around find eight megabytes
and found out the complex queries the
joint was into tables they ran under a
minute so so I showed that the two kinds
of quiz the p time in the shopping
complete queries the p10 queries they do
not have any overhead overhead over
traditional queries and they actually
run pretty fast the the sharpie compute
square is they are in order thanks dude
slow but they still ran in under a
minute for the for a half a gigabyte
database and if you want to do
optimizations like drop k or you can you
can actually compute some sub queries
which are which are safe plant cell you
come you run a simulation top perfect
with this optimizations you can't just
speed up the queries
lish
so the complex to the results that you
have is easily this is a fashion of the
schema that it's at the schema level I
can look at a coup any and then answer
if I can match it in this safeway or not
but have you also considered instance
level like as an exaggerated example if
every couple has a rowdy one you can
answer everything in a safe plan so it
might happen that you're eighty-five
percent of edibles are probably one and
a very small treasure so it's possible
that you can have this entire slew of
techniques that that look at the actual
probabilities and not and not it the
schema of the uncertainty yeah that's a
good question and their two ways you can
go about it so you can use some
constraints on the database to describe
some additional properties that your
database satisfies and then you can use
it to optifine safe plans for Paris
which did not have the advanced the fine
stance we have we do take care of the
functional dependencies and key
constraints in the database to actually
compute safe plans for the queries which
which did not have saved a little ways
so that's one way to go about it the
other way you look at each of the triple
and all the triples are generated at
that triple and some for sahaja to pass
it would be very hard to compute the
probability for some other trippers it
can compute it by just observing that
all the input tuples had probability 1
or if you get a very simple expression
so you can you can do a fine-grained
optimization where for some papers to
compute the probability of directly and
for some triples to do a simulation
thanks